I'm Tiara Fletcher and I'm Myron
Fletcher we are rocket scientists and
today we'll be answering your questions
from Twitter this is rocket support
[Music]
at bait Master OG why do rocket ships
launch straight up instead of at an
angle like a plane it's because the way
thrust is propelled out of rockets if
you launch the rocket sideways you
wouldn't have the counteraction of the
ground being able to push from the
hardest part about launching a rocket is
truly getting off the ground so that's
when you're experiencing your greatest
amount of gravity and that's when you
need the greatest amount of thrust a
rocket takes off straight like this but
once it's in the air we can use thrust
Factor controls to turn the rocket in
any direction that we would like for it
to go in so it doesn't go straight out
of the Earth's atmosphere like this it
actually comes in at an inclination like
this rotations are like this they're not
like this and so in order to get out of
a rotation it's better to go with the
rotation than trying to go through the
rotation and so therefore Rockets will
have an inclination to go out sideways
versus straightforward at poligowski 66x
what is the skinny on Mr musk's new
rocket engine so the Raptor 2 engine
produces about 510 000 pounds of thrust
and this is actually comparable to the
rs-25 engines that are used for the
space launch system they will be
utilized for the Starship the Starship
is a super heavy launch vehicle produced
by SpaceX and I know that for Elon Musk
he has a huge goal of going to Mars so
the Starship would be the vehicle to
achieve that goal for him it's predicted
to have about 33 of these rocket engines
so looking at about 17 million pounds of
thrust that'll be produced from the
Starship so that's a major difference
from the space launch system which
produces about 8.8 million pounds of
thrust SLS only uses four engines where
Starship would use 33 engines and so if
they can figure out how to get all those
engines to fire off at the same time
every time they're going to have a very
very powerful rocket on their hands so
the Starship could take the crown for
the most powerful rocket in history at
somebody Hello Lee what are parts of a
rocket well a simple rocket consists of
a structural system which would include
your nose cone and your fins as well as
a propulsive system right so a small
engine that would go inside of a model
rocket for instance the reasons you have
fins is because these fins causes the
rocket to be stable and so this fan
actually causes downforce to take place
now when you're talking about a more
complex rocket such as NASA space launch
system you are looking at a repulsive
system but your propulsive system is
going to include these solid rocket
boosters here which includes solid
propellant and those solid rocket
boosters might look familiar they're
actually from the space shuttle program
just a little bit modified another
section has been added to them and the
solid Rockets are important because they
provide about 90 percent of the thrust
needed to get Space line system off the
ground but then you also have liquid
propellant in the form of liquid
hydrogen and liquid oxygen but then here
you're wondering where would the
astronauts or the payloads go inside of
the Orion capsule and that is where the
Orion capsule sits and together you have
your space launch system at Philip Ben X
may be a dumb question but why are
rocket engines that loud what exactly is
making that sound so the thrust that
these Rockets are throwing out is
actually going past the speed of sound
and because it's going past the speed of
sound it creates these whiplashes are
known as shock waves these shock waves
then cause rumbles to happen and
vibrations to take place and all of this
together creates the noise and that's
why it's so loud at Ian Vincent Scott
acts so what fuel is powering the rocket
ship that NASA is sending to the Moon
that's a space launch system is using
liquid hydrogen and liquid oxygen now
very very cold liquid normally known as
cryogenic negative 423 degrees
Fahrenheit for liquid hydrogen and
negative 297 degrees for liquid oxygen
when you combine those two the fuel in
the oxidizer you get combustion called
thrust and you get about 2 million
pounds of Thrust out of those systems
the solid rocket boosters are made up of
proprietary material and that material
is a hard material that is lit together
from the inside out which creates
threads for those solid rocket boosters
memes
brackets burn fuel in space if there is
an oxygen
oxygen in the combustion chamber you
have the fuel and oxygen when they meet
each other that's called combustion that
combustion causes thrust in order for
combustion to take place you need oxygen
a rocket actually has its own Fuel and
oxidizer on board even though there is
an oxygen in space it brings its own
oxygen source with it at the Lucy asks
what makes a rocket a rocket is there a
guideline does it need to go to space a
rocket is anything that is a structure
with a propulsive system and a nose cone
a prime example of a great rocket would
be a firecracker a firecracker is a
rocket because it has a propulsion
system at Mo art will acts why build the
other parts of a rocket ship if they are
going to separate mid-air and where do
the remnants fall your prowl for rockets
that are heading into space they are
actually multi-stage so once a stage is
completely depleted of its fuel you no
longer need it so these two particular
solid rocket boosters they're the first
to fall off for the space launch system
and then you have the core stage the
liquid hydrogen and the liquid oxygen
once those are completely depleted you
no longer need this entire foreign
states where do those pieces fall
typically into the ocean anything is
close to the coast was the best place to
shoot off and right most parts that land
into the ocean there aren't reusable
Parts but now they're actually Landing
those parts on Space barges which are
reusable
at 23x how to Rockets land like don't
they just go straight up and down yeah
there are a few companies right now that
are using reusable rockets that are
causing them to land back on the earth
gorgeous SpaceX are two prime examples
their Rockets will lunge off into the
atmosphere and then they'll send their
payloads off into deep space and then
the actual booster parts will come back
down to earth safely and they'll
actually cause thrust to come out of the
rocket right before it lands causing it
to slow down and give it a cushion it's
a very complicated process to make that
happen very very it's like causing a
pencil to land on its eraser at real
Mark Ridley how do rockets get built for
large Rockets such as the space launch
system it truly is a nationwide effort
and also even International where it
takes thousands of suppliers is coming
together in order to get this one rocket
built you got to start at the component
level that the parts that are that you
can physically see and touch and some
that you can't physically see and touch
those parts are built at suppliers All
Over America once they're tested they're
all shipped down to machine assembly
facility in New Orleans and in New
Orleans you have a group of test
engineers and production Engineers who
actually put the parts together and once
they're put together we then send it
over to stennis in Mississippi where we
actually hot fire the rocket and that's
where we run a full duration test with
liquid hydrogen and liquid oxygen once
that test is completed the NASA
Engineers are happy we then shoot it
over to Kennedy Space Center there we
actually put it on a lunch stand and
from there we actually caused the rocket
to go into space and those are the steps
to how you build a rocket edited think
of X what would be the next huge
revolutionary advancement in rocket
propulsion warp drive nuclear propulsion
go ahead propulsion guy Rick currently
have nuclear propulsion systems nuclear
propulsion sounds great but let's just
wait until we start shooting a bunch of
nukes in there and figure out if other
countries don't get mad about it so
based on the theoretical limits that
we've studied so far there is a
possibility that one day we might be
able to travel at light speed we
possibly can with Fusion technology so
there are technologies that are out
there that are currently still being
developed they're on very small scales
right now but one day they'll be
commercially available and we might have
wart drop in our own lifetime one thing
that's critical here that you have to
counter for is human factors body can
only withstand so much gravity and so
when you start exerting that amount of
pressure and that amount of of energy on
the body the Technologies might be there
to propel us to go light speed but can
our bodies withstand that speed that is
an interesting handle I'm gonna try at
d-van remortel
can Rockets be used to intercept
asteroids and redirect him NASA actually
completed a mission called Dart double
asteroid redirection test to test and
see if we can actually defend our planet
and we successfully did when that probe
hit the asteroid it actually caused the
momentum to change of that asteroid
which caused its orbit to slow down by
33 minutes there could come a day where
a super huge asteroid comes our way so
now we can use all of the momentum
transfer data so we can figure out how
big that spacecraft needs to be how fast
it needs to go compared to whatever
asteroid is coming our way at hula
gangster X what's the difference between
rockets and ballistic missiles rackets
and ballistic missiles are built very
similarly the only difference is the
payload the different payloads is one is
carrying humans and the other one is
clarium Warheads at Blake and band what
is harder rocket science or brain
surgery coming from a rocket scientist I
think is rocket science
listen brain surgery is difficult you
are dealing with one of the most
important organs of the human body so
just one small centimeter even smaller
than that you can literally disable
someone you know with rocket science if
you're off by one centimeter by one
micrometer you can cause catastrophic
failures to take place hey I do rocket
science every day and it is quite
difficult so I just can't choose between
the two they're both just hard at Shea
pain 14 acts like why can't I just be
like Jimmy Neutron and just build
rockets in my backyard and stuff well
actually you can there's an entire
Society National Association of rocketry
all around the United States amateurs
are building rockets in their backyards
and we ourselves we actually built
rockets in our backyard all the time now
if the rocket happens to go above 3218
feet you're going to have to get a
regulatory agreement from the Nars
Society or these other societies to say
that you can fly that rocket otherwise
you might interfere with somebody's
passenger flight at T Bieber believer X
I'm confused what's the difference
between a spaceship space shuttle and a
rocket a shuttle for instance is
something that's going to carry humans
into space and back down into Earth
that's why it's called a shuttle it
literally carries humans in and out a
spaceship could be used interchangeably
with the space shuttle but if you're
talking about a specific spaceship
you're usually talking about something
that's going in between different orbits
a rocket is simply a structural body
that you can launch it has a propulsion
system so it can be your fireworks or it
could be the space launch system at
Noman at least 7147 how do rockets or
Moon missions get back to Earth from the
Moon let's say you have a spacecraft
orbiting the moon then you reach a point
where you want to return to Earth you
then need to understand what is the
amount of thrust or what is the amount
of drag that I have to overcome in order
to escape this orbit when you come out
of the moon's orbit it has its own
gravitational force in order to come out
of that orbit you have to slingshot
yourself out of that orbit so you use
thrust in order to slingshot out of the
moon's orbit to get into Earth's orbit
so you go from a lunar orbit to a
geosynchronous orbit is what we call it
and once you get into the geosynchronous
orbit you decrease your speed so that
you can come back to earth you slow down
a spacecraft by using reverse thrusters
spacecrafts normally have thrusters on
the front and the back and so when
you're going into these different orbits
you will actually fire those reverse
thrusters to actually slow you down you
then want to deploy parachutes so you
can have as soft of a landing as
possible at Angel Yuki ax how do rockets
know exactly where they have to go
guidance navigation and control and all
those systems come in together and it's
called control torque and that's also
known as gimbaling the gimbals are
located at the front of the engines here
these are rs-25 engines that are located
for the space launch system and by using
gimbaling we're able to slightly move
those engines on the order of about 10
to 12 degrees and we're able to slightly
adjust the rocket in such a way to
correct this trajectory as we see fit
just like a ship right a ship has a it's
a really really big object and has a
little bitty Rudder that causes this
ship to steer left and right it's the
same way with the rocket 300 120 feet
tall and 10 degrees can cause a rocket
to steer left and right at Mike's
barrero X who was Katherine Johnson
Catherine Johnson was an amazing woman
and she was one of the first African
Academy for NASA she was a mathematician
she was responsible for doing the
trajectories for the freedom 7 Mission
as well as the Friendship seven Mission
as part of project Mercury and those
were actually our first human flights
for the United States of America at
space science 73 asked what is the
coolest rocket launch ever a little
biased but NASA's space launch system is
the most powerful racket ever launched
in history so it's my favorite what
about you Maya I would say NASA space
launch system as well the reason being
we had a very very powerful rocket
launch and take a capsule as far as
we've ever sent it we've never seen a
capsule that are going to cure humans as
far as we've sent that capsule to me
that's the coolest thing that you can do
as a rocket scientist at Alec the
Destroyer X yo how you become a rocket
scientist so for us it starts with the
degree you go to school to become an
aerospace engineer in this degree you're
going to have to go through calculus one
calculus 2 calculus 3 differential
equations a lot of math and then you
have to have the science part physics
one for physics too but then you go into
orbital mechanics you're going to have
to study aerodynamics you're going to
have to study Dynamic statistics Statics
and then you're also going to study
different things like propulsion
computer aided design in different
fields like that with the aerospace
engineering degree at Lionel media acts
what was Operation Paperclip so
Operation Paperclip was an intelligence
operation that took place to get a bunch
of German scientists over to the United
States we got to pick their brains
understand how they were building the V2
rocket one of the German scientists that
we brought over was actually called
Wander Von Braun and he was the director
of the Marshall space flight center now
he was a Visionary he really wanted us
to get to Mars and so the Saturn V was a
bit overly built you can read more about
it in the Mars project one of the books
that he published in the 50s but he was
definitely one of the founding fathers
of our space program at interrobang 2x
will Humanity ever leave the solar
system really really good question so
we've actually had spacecraft that
actually have left our solar system
Voyager 1 and Voyager 2. Now Voyager One
one and two were launched back in the
70s and they just now made it outside of
the solar system so you can imagine
putting humans on a rocket for 30 40
years how that'll turn out but the
possibility is definitely there current
propulsion Technologies could expedite
that 40 or 50 year Journey but it's
still a long way to go and those probes
are out there learning more about that
environment before we put a human into
that space so those are all the
questions for today those were a lot of
great questions and if you're interested
in learning more about rocket science we
definitely encourage you to pursue it
thanks for watching Rocket support